give me some good news Dave well how
about this one Whoopi Goldberg's leaving
Twitter
so it has been a little over a week
since Elon Musk took over Twitter and
places it it's a mess he's already
called back some of the workforce he
fired a few days ago he's putting his
Eight dollar charge for blue check
verification or hold first it was going
to be twenty dollars now it's going to
be eight dollars he also suspended Kathy
Griffin for impersonating him on a
parody account uh
which has started a free Cappy hashtag
to Trent I mean I'm I'm I I'm getting
off I'm getting off today because I just
feel like you know it's it's so messy
yeah and I I'm tired of now
having had certain kinds of attitudes
blocked and now they're back on and I
just I'm gonna get out and if it settles
down and I feel more comfortable yeah
maybe I'll come back but as of tonight
I'm done with
there's so much here so first off I
found out during the clip uh whoopee is
worth approximately 60 million dollars
so let's go on the assumption that she
can afford the eight dollars or the
twenty dollars it's eight but I'm gonna
go on the Assumption she can afford it
that's one thing uh but now what she's
really upset by was what she said at the
end there were certain types of
attitudes that were blocked before and
now they're back there are people
literally on Twitter right now who
believe things that Whoopi Goldberg does
not believe she can't be on a platform
with those people she's on The View only
with people who who agree with her all
day long
it's so incredible you know I always
talk about that thin viewer of veneer of
Tolerance that progressives have like
they seem tolerant and then you peel
this thing off and then it's just sort
of this crazy hysterical angry lunatic
it's like that is what Whoopi is and
it's unfortunate she was a great actress
right when she was in ghost Molly you in
danger girl I remember I saw it at the
movie theaters I loved it Sister Act
Sister Act two I've done this before
what else has she been in she was in uh
soap dish come on give me a give me a
Whoopi Goldberg movie she was in help me
here guys what else was she in she was
in uh The Color Purple I'm doing this
off the top of my head she was in uh did
they do a sister act three
which one
she was in The Little Rascals thank you
Phoenix all right the point is she was a
decent actress and now she's just
because these people so this idea of now
there's voices on there that were booted
that are back it's like so you're okay
censoring people do you not see that
makes you the bad guy